FOR THE FIRST
HACLJUST RELEASED DATAM E 2020
USPOM 10INK ABOUT THIS CONTEXT
CLES IT'S HUGE.W POLA
.8% OF THE
E UL
T OF T COMING FROMULATION OVER.
IT'S THE BIGGEST SGROUP.MAKING
SO THIS IS AS THE DATA SHOONTH
WEST.
S NOA
SURPRISE.
CRUCIAL, BEE USED TRE
MIDTERM TID IT EFOREYE
DETERMINESHE.
"OFRDAVE WASSERMAN, A
U.S. HOUSE EDITOR OF THE.CARDON
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR AND VANI
THAT JUST CAME OUT
AT TWA
S  ANTRY THATO GET MORMONHISPANT
PO TPRECENSU
ATTHED SE . UNDERCOUNATOFS FEAR
IN FACT,18.7OFS.ULEVEN A0t A HI.
FOR DEMOCRATS,NTOMIG CHICAGO AND
,
THAN THEATES SUGGE
AND THOSE ARE  WHES ARE REALLYIN
DRAW THE LINES IN EIR  MOVING I'
REDIRECTING.
AT
VANTAGE WHEN IING THBODAT .LD GD
TE
ADVAAGLORIDA, NORTH GEORGIA, AND
FIO TAKE BACK HOE CONTRO>> RIGH.
OFS ATSTAND HE
THWHON S
BUT SO DOETHE
SP A
IOLOT OF IT IN THED.
RESIDENT TT DECADEF OF THOSEIDE.
ST WT TO CHALLENGE THEASSUMPTIOT
WEUTT CAME PAN
AFTER CAMPAIGN
NE
SO ALL THISPIC, T  MOCRATS OR C
THE MORE DIV GOOD FOR THE
T IS FOR PIE    POCISN'T M
GOING TO BE A FI BE FIGHT.
TO YOUR QUESTION, WHPA
WILL BFOR?
G TO BE GOOD FDECRAPHICS IS NOT
E BEENE TOE W NUMB
ILL REALLY GUS CONTINUE TOGHT.
BU H HAVAGATTTE NO
POPULATION, THE MUACIAL ON COUN.
AT THE VERY BEGINNHT.OFO
THOADE
HERE, OF COURSE,
ARE SOME WHO ARE DEE
CONCERNED AND UPSET ABOUT ISE
TUCKERARLSON, WHO HA
RHISWS.
>>HEC PARTY IS
ELECTORATHCASTING BAPLE,RRT
MORE OBET VOTERSD.
DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGE IS THE KEY T
THE POPULATION OF THE TO CHANGE
THE ADMINISTRATIONNGELLE
RY
U NG LIKE
IS BR THEY T WFOR THEM.
Y. VAN, JUST THE POINT OUSLY,
NO
WATER, R?D THE ASE OWUSD AIN, R?
IT'S RESINLE
HOW COME?>> UH-HUH.
WELL, LOOK, CHANGE IS HARD.
ON THAT AND DEMAGOGUE.DYS D STAR
DEMO
THEY'RE COMINGO THEDO  TN PARTY
THAT'SVIATINO
COMMUNITY INTO THETI
WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE THEM.
T
ETHIC, BIG FAITH BKGYOU HAVE TOR
REPUBLICAN PARTY TRE
MANY VOTERO SOMEF
NATURALLY SHOULD BE VOTING FORT
VOPLE ARE HERE TO WORK AND REPCA
NASTY, AND HO
THEY'RE DRIVING AWAY V
EYE.
THIS DEMOGRA CHANGE COULHELP EIB
DEMOATOF
WITH EYEWI OPEN.O
ARNTEO
ARE EATING UD WILL UP.ESIDENT TS
N THREY S COUNTRY
ST WHITET
K DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGEY ISERSCORD
THER TR TR WHOPE I SE TICS  THI
COUNTRY, AND LOOK AT THE  A PIE
WE'REENU IN E  E HAH OFUNDER 18R
NON-ITMEANS RE OF THIS, TH
FUTURE LEADERS OF THISLL BE , HE
POHICH THEN WILL
POINMA MAKING, 18, T
WH.T THAT WHITES ARE BS
SO ONE OTHSTEST GROWING
TR THESTFI
>> YEAH.EMENCOMMUNITIES.
SO LOOK, GEORGIA IS DOWN TO 50%T
SO YOU SEE THI OF M
NECEARG REPUAN IRONY I20PRESID
ELECTI F, WAS THAT HE DE THE
THOSE URBACOUNTIES. THE THE CS
'S THOSERBHICH ARE
GAINEDATION.HAT ARE
COUNTIES TRY TH
PULATION.ING STILL FAVORS
REPUBLICANS.
>>ND
FOUR YEARS SINCE THE RALLY IN
CHARLOTTESVILLE.CENSUSD
COUNTRY, BEEP
SP
>> YEAH.
I STILL DON'T THINK THE COUNTRY
SEEING N MN ICYOU EN LOT OF
PEOPLE, SHOCKED A LOOFEOSOME SA
CONTEXT, BUT HE WAS NOT ABLE TO
PEOPVEN'T AND THE REALITY IS, A
WORLD BECAUSE WE GET IN THE
AND STEAL TALENTM
,  GOT THE HARDEST
COO OUR .
CUTTING OUR OWN OFFLL THINT T
T US.
WE SHOUL